I read the book because it's a novel and
it's a suspense novel and it's actually
about stuff that you and I are very
interested which is in America 1950s the
political late 50s political figures
that are involved Joe McCarthy John F
Kennedy when he was a Senator Robert
Kennedy Bobby Kennedy he's involved in
the hearings and so all these great
characters are in there and so it's a
very it's a great book faintly fun read
and I think people would enjoy it and
that got me thinking audio book I heard
there's an audio book I did I did the
audio version you did it I did it yes
okay I've written non-fiction books
before and other people did the audio
version but but but I did the the audio
tape of this this begs the question you
have all these characters that we all
know from those three like a younger
john f kennedy's there and a younger
robert kennedy and you got Joe McCarthy
running around you got all these
different people who's doing you get
celebrities to do those voices no I did
the voices I did the voices do you do
the voices as them yes I figured if I
did it and people were listening to it
they would want a little bit of
differentiation in the dialogue and so I
listened to what they sounded like and I
and I so for instance I know and you
know this because I know you're on the
board of the Kennedy Library John F
Kennedy he talks a little like down here
and then Robert Kenny he's a little high
right and so I tried to do them all I
tried to do McCarthy's Wisconsin voice
and Eisenhower's you know Kansas twang
and you know it was fun it is you can
read the book you can read this book as
a fun suspense novel and then there's
lots of fun historical tidbits it's the
one of the reasons that years ago I got
into reading Gore Vidal's he wrote such
great oh he's the best yeah
really good